supuesto que hablando de la Champions
League este torneo de prestigio en
Europa que nos podemos esperar en este
comienzo de la fase de grupo Más allá de
las sorpresas que son habituales ya en
los últimos años y también Qué equipos
se armaron mejor de Cara a este torneo
Bueno yo creo que tenemos cinco posibles
candidatos ya De antemano incluso
empezando esta fase de grupos hay que
empezar por el Real Madrid que la
temporada pasada revalido el concepto de
lo que es la jerarquía además enfocados
con un entrenador que no solo hizo mejor
a sus jugadores sino que también
potenció un colectivo de manera
interesante tener 14 Champions en sus
vitrinas Yo creo que es suficiente
palmarés para empezar como uno de los
grandes candidatos en esta nueva
temporada luego tenemos al Manchester
City un City que de nuevo de la mano de
Pep Guardiola intentará lograr esta
Champions League recordemos que estuvo
en la final frente a Chelsea hace un par
de años y luego en la pasada temporada
quedó eliminado a manos del Real Madrid
tuvo dos bajas tiene dos bajas la de
Sterling y Gabriel Jesús sin embargo se
reforzó muy bien yo los goles de jalan y
de la gran Perla del fútbol argentino
como es Julián Álvarez jalan ya tienen
esta temporada 10 goles en apenas seis
partidos en la Premier League Yo creo
que es un grandísimo refuerzo por otro
lado está El rey del fútbol alemán el
Bayern Munich uno de los equipos con más
intensidad Y capacidad ofensiva en toda
Europa que se reforzó con sabiomania uno
de los grandes talentos de Liverpool y
que sin duda Aunque perdió lewandowski
seguirás peleando y siempre es uno de
los grandes candidatos a pelear por la
Champions League luego Tenemos que irnos
a hablar del Liverpool un Liverpool que
no arranca bien en la Premier League y
que ha tenido pues dificultades con las
lesiones que ha presentado en este
inicio de temporada pero que cuenta con
un trabajo de siete años de jürgen klopp
y además también sumó a Darwin Núñez una
gran figura del fútbol uruguayo y yo
creo que estos momentos de acoplamiento
que ha sufrido estas dificultades ya lo
va a tener preparado para para asumir
esta primera ronda sin mucha dificultad
y cerraría con el París Saint Germain
rápidamente christoff gattie ahora al
frente de este gran proyecto yo creo que
este tridente que no ha logrado estar
acoplado en la mayor parte de las
pasadas temporadas en inicia muy bien
tiene 17 goles y luego yo creo que
también se reforzaron muy bien en el
mediocampo tres contrataciones muy
importantes como es la de vitiña Fabián
Ruiz y Renato Sánchez yo creo que hasta
desde ahí empezará a construir un equipo
mucho más sólido para avanzar en las
diferentes rondas de esta Champions
League y veremos Si por fin se le da el
título de la Champions al París Saint
Germain Pero por otro lado en nuestro
continente se disputan las semifinales
de la Copa Libertadores tres equipos
brasileños y uno argentino luchan por
llegar a la final que se celebrará en
Guayaquil en la ida flamengo venció
cuatro goles por 0 a Vélez sarsfield de
Argentina el tiempo que paranaen se
venció Un gol por cero al palmeiras Sara
porque estamos viendo este amplio
dominio de Brasil sobre todo en los
últimos torneos y que prácticamente
están un paso de una tercera final con
equipos brasileños yo creo que
potenciaron mucho sus proyectos desde el
mercado hablamos de un mercado brasilero
que logró después de dificultades por
ejemplo flamengo con dificultades
financieras de lograr sanear unos clubes
y además llamar la atención de jugadores
de Gran potencial en Europa lo cual
aumenta el valor de su marca estamos
hablando de un flamengo que por ejemplo
tiene Una nómina de más de 160 millones
de euros que eso en el Continente pues
evidentemente es muy difícil de igualar
esto sumado como digo también a
proyectos deportivos muy fuertes yo creo
que lo que se ha visto en flamengo
primero con georgie Jesús y ahora en el
proyecto actual demuestra cuando rival
Junior que que es un equipo con
muchísimas posibilidades lo que vimos
frente a Vélez que eran estos otros
animadores los los argentinos siempre
intentando hacer esa contraposición en
el fútbol sudamericano deja en evidencia
que esto es este fútbol que empieza a
hacer de mucha exportación de jugadores
termina disminuyendo eh digamos la
competitividad de la liga y en ese
sentido también hace difícil que se
compita a nivel continental la sorpresa
fue la de Atlético paranaense con un
viejo conocido de esta Copa Libertadores
como es Luis Felipe escolar y al frente
del equipo que ganó ese primer partido
frente a palmeiras pero sin duda
palmeiras con Abel Ferreira también
tiene mucho que dar en este partido de
vuelta y hay que tomar en cuenta que es
el actual bicampeón de ese torneo